Hey YouTubers it's Charlie this is going to
be my terminator Genesis review Khaleesi Sarah
Connor taking over for Cersei Sarah Connor
in case you guys didn't remember this is actually
the fifth terminator movie but the six terminator
installment because of the TV series with
Lena Headey that was a Fox show from a long
time ago but if you dig really deep you can
actually find the episodes you can definitely
chart different eras in the franchise you
have like the James Cameron era with those
first two films then you then you have like
the middle films that we can forget about
number three and four the of the TV era was
Cersei Lannister in Summer Glau and now we
have Daenerys Targaryen Sarah Connor the real
question is is how do you tell a new in interesting
story and the terminator universe when the
premise is always the same machines trying
to defeat man by changing the timeline typically
the way the previous terminator films have
addressed this is that you go back to different
points in time or you have films that focus
on different characters inside the paradigm
I said this film has the most in common with
the first terminator film it honors a lot
of very specific moments from that very first
film so if you want to prepare for this like
if you not to see till this weekend I would
re-watch the original terminator film is all
it does just enough I winking without being
too nostalgic for the film just like never
quite finds its emotional core I just handed
to him that the writers definitely try to
leave behind some of the pre-assumption that
you have going into this and you know in that
Jon Connor plays a certain role, Reese and
Sarah Connor have have their own roles then
you have the bad terminators the of the sympathetic
terminator usually each of the films themselves
try to, shuffle the Cast in the way that they
focus on that core group this film definitely
has a little fun with that but I feel like
it's never connects with you on on the visceral
level of the movie say like mad Max Fury Road
it's not a totally fair comparison because
I feel like inside this terminator universe
there a lot more story constraints than there
are with the like mad Max that film wasn't
quite is burdened as the terminator films
are with certain predetermined story points
as and you know machines take over humans
try to go back in time to change the past
so that they can defeat the machines it makes
me think a lot about what's going to be going
on with with the flash season two now that
they've introduced time travel on that show
is like how do you explain the logic of time
travel without getting too silly so the film
addresses that it in a really funny way and
everybody's wondering about Emilia Clark because
you see starting to break into like some really
big mainstream movies now she doesn't quite
hold a candle to Linda Hamilton but but again
there there really trying to do something
different with these characters so I tried
to make too many direct comparisons with with
other parts trails of that character like
Lena Headey Sarah Connor very different from
Emilia Clark Sarah Connor the changes in her
character are totally explain by the logic
of the film so so it's not a really big issue
I don't want to say too much about Matt Smith's
role because he was a lot of fun he was one
of my top three characters in the film but
the explain his role any more than that it
is a bit spoilery Jason Clarke probably my
second favorite performance in the film your
behind and Clark as Sarah Connor this is really
her film is much as the first terminator film
is Linda Hamilton's film there's a certain
point in the the James Cameron arrow where
the film shifted in like terminator two became
all about Jon Connor were is the first film
is all about Sarah Connor the problem with
the story I think is is that it doesn't follow
her story and am in a meaningful way it's
almost like halfway through the film the story
shifts perspectives and in the the whole film
tries to build around a different character
where is your your con expecting to be about
Emilia Clark I understand the trying to do
something new but but I feel like it really
kind takes you out of the story and you, lose
your emotional connection with Sarah Connor
sometimes when the cast certain actors in
a film like to get a really big actor the
though change the story to feature the more
and sometimes that works sometimes it doesn't
I feel in this case it does not and I'm not
talking about the governor later Arnold Schwarzenegger
does talk about his performance he will always
and forever be the terminator along you know
if Robert Patrick of the T 1000 with to give
him credit to a new most every major story
to tell about the movie going into its of
there were a whole lot of surprises in terms
of plot twists but there is one really nice
moment you need to keep your eyes peeled for
that they kind of honors the legacy of Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Robert Patrick I have no
idea what their plans for the future the series
are the the rights of been passed around a
lot of different places that's one of the
reasons why took so long to get this film
off the ground the film does a good job of
closing this story so that he can exist by
itself and it's not like a big middle finger
ending where where there's a cliffhanger that's
completely unexplained so you will walk away
feeling like you got cheated out of an ending
but deaf definitely expect more terminator
films whether they come in two years or four
years or five years that they'll come there
will be more terminator. My big question for
you guys when you get a chance to see terminator
let me know what your favorite part of the
film and what you want to see them do with
the franchise in the next installment I mean
like what can you do that's new with terminator
that we haven't seen before I would hope that
they would have the guts to focus on different
characters and just go with that just just
leave pre-existing characters behind like
maybe you take one or two but you don't stick
to the old paradigm that's why get really
excited when I when I hear about movies like
Star Trek three they they just announced that
it's called Star Trek beyond their like it
is definitely not going to be the search for
Spock which was the original third movie with
that with the same cast but a doubly give
a giant thumbs-up to Emilia Clark's performance
Jamie she's my favorite part of the film I
feel like any shortcomings of the film or
the fault of the script Alan Taylor's the
director he directed a lot of game of thrones
these work with the movie Clark before he
also directed Thor the dark world he's done
some some big stuff he's a fairly competent
director so feel like most of the issues with
this movie are with the story itself with
the script but is still definitely worth checking
out so go check it out and then come back
on this video let me know what you think just
to be careful to use spoiler tags if you if
you have seen it just because most people
probably won't see this till the weekend so
there's a whole bunch of stuff happening this
week I'm slowly getting ready for comic con
so I'm going to start rolling those videos out in between
flash and Marvel stuff so be sure to subscribe
to get everything it's going to be a lot of
fun, while you guys wait for that stuff to post you can
click here for my latest game of thrones video
from yesterday and you can click here to learn
about what's going on with guardians the galaxy
2 thank you so much for watching, everybody
let's high five and I'll see you guys tonight!